the dream of the overwatch league for me
has always been completely unrelated to
what might happen behind the business of
it if we really want a sports to be
celebrated we have to look at other
forms of entertainment or sports that
are doing things very successfully and
borrow from them and be inspired from
them and go look let's not keep this
thing precious to ourselves it's not the
band that I discovered and I'm the only
one who's allowed to be into let's
really you know put this on the main
stage and have a lot of people start to
enjoy this thing because it's awesome
and everybody deserves to enjoy it
whether it's rallying a cluster of
pixels back and forth in pong chasing
high schools at the arcade in Donkey
Kong or coming together as teams in
first-person shooters for as long as
video games have existed competition has
been a central pillar in recent years
the term eSport has become a popular way
to refer to organized competitions in
games players square off in virtual
arenas for glory while on lookers are
treated to seeing the most popular games
played at the very highest levels but as
an industry eSports is still very much
in its infancy the lion's share of its
history is one of grassroots efforts
small communities brought together by
their love of a game a desire to share
experiences with like-minded fans and
the drive to prove themselves the best
it's only recently that a formalized
industry has formed around these
competitions however although video
games are a hundred billion dollar
business eSports is a very small slice
of that pie the viewership of popular
events such as League of Legends world's
dota twos the International and Evo pale
in comparison to those of traditional
sports for that to change it needs to
break out from the confines of a niche
form of entertainment targeted at the
hardcore enthusiasts and reach a broader
audience for developer blizzard
entertainment the global popularity of
its team-based shooter overwatch has
created the opportunity to do this it
hopes that by infusing competitive
overwatch with the thrill of watching a
live traditional sports event it can
bring eSports to the masses in this
series we're going to be exploring
blizzards vision for overwatch as a
spectator sports looking at how they're
establishing overwatch League as the
premier eSports organization over the
next five episodes will speak to key
figures involved at every level from the
games director and the league's
Commissioner to production staff team
owners players and fans all to get a
better understanding of blizzards
ambitions each episode will focus on one
of the key pillars that Blizzard has put
in place to support its lofty ambitions
and will reflect on what the company has
achieved so far as well as what it hopes
to achieve in the future
[Music]
[Music]
I'm a dancer commissure the overwash
League my first day of loser was on
Halloween in 2014 and I'm a second day
in the office my boss called me in and
said hey check this out and he played
for me the announce trailer for
overwatch and very early on in my
experiences with the game and I think
this was experience that a lot of us had
and certainly when playing the game was
like this game is really really good
this game's gonna do very well people
are gonna want to play this game
competitively we knew when we were
making overwatch as a game that it was
going to be a highly competitive
experience the goal was to make a
competitive 6v6 action shooter that was
out of the gate what we set out to do
now we told ourselves naively we're not
going to worry about this being an
eSport yet just yet we want it to be a
competitive game but it doesn't
necessarily have to be an eSport within
months of having the first playable
versions of the game up and running the
team was already playing it so
competitively that we resigned ourselves
this is going to be an eSport whether we
like it or not there's so much depth to
the game and there's really something
for everybody if you want to be the guy
you can go play Ginji and you can try to
carry if you want to support you can do
that if you want to take you can do that
if you want to do I don't know if you
want to have a turret and be a very
small Swedish man you can do that
anybody who has played of any
first-person shooter can find value in a
game like overwatch right because you
already know there's a familiarity there
you can say oh I know what this game is
you got deep yes you have healers you
have tanks there's a level of comfort
there and familiarity I think at the
core of any
of experience there has to be a sense of
team play and a sense of competing
objectives and that's what you have in
overwatch you have two teams who both
either want the same thing like in the
example of the control map they both
want to take control of the point or in
our other examples where there is an
attack defense scenario going on one
team has an objective to take something
the other team has the objective of
defending it and it creates an immediate
competitive experience add to that high
level of player skill required and a
high level of coordination and it
immediately puts people in sort of a
competitive mindset the similarities
between overwatch and real world sports
such as football soccer and basketball
are immediately apparent a group of
players each fulfilling a specific role
to overcome the differences of an
opposing team and achieve an objective
it makes sense then that when it came to
thinking about how to present overwatch
as an eSport Blizzard looked to the
Premier League NFL NHL and NBA for
inspiration and so as a part of the work
I was doing sort of came up with an idea
that I at the time called the overwatch
Premier League and it was like hey let's
take a page out of the book from
traditional sports and apply that to
overwatch because this game is sort of
perfect for it it's team-based 6p6 its
global it's set on earth like there was
just all these sort of pieces that in my
mind made a lot of sense to build a
sports league for overwatch that looked
like traditional sports when we were
developing overwatch we were really
cognizant of professional sport the
whole time we're making the game and we
were looking at a lot of other shooters
that were out at that time and in most
of those you cared more about what your
personal score was and you didn't care
so much if the team had won or lost and
also taking a real close look at the mo
buffets that we were we were seeing
games like League of Legends dota 2
heroes of the storm we realized that
there was this
high-value in getting the competitive
spirit going in the team aspect of it
all of us across the team have our
different sports that were you know fans
of we have NFL fans NHL fans MLB fans on
the team so as we were creating the game
we talked a lot about the core game
design and how we wanted you to feel at
the end of a match one of the most
emotional moments for me in my life and
this is I'm like a little sad and
embarrassed to say this but I grew up as
a hockey fan and I grew up in Los
Angeles and our hometown team is the Los
Angeles Kings and they had never won a
Stanley Cup until 2012 and my brother
and I who had grown up together being LA
Kings fans and always watching them lose
or not make the playoffs it was so much
personal investment that we had in this
team that the day that they won the
Stanley Cup my brother and I were both
in the stadium we could only afford
seats in the very last row so I was
literally at the the last row of the
Staples Center and then watching the
moment when they hoisted the cup over
their head it stuck with me for months
like it wasn't just like this brief like
happy moment like oh cool my team won
the game it changed me when the LA Kings
won that Stanley Cup and that I was
there with my brother and I'd like to
think that moments like that can and
should be happening to people with
eSports it's no different people just
haven't discovered it yet
in the eyes of Blizzard
emotionally-charged moments like these
are the key to overwatch league success
and its adoption as a spectator sport
that anyone and everyone can enjoy in
traditional sports landmark events such
as Michael Jordan's iconic leap during
the NBA slam dunk contest in 1988 our
lead knocking out Foreman during rumble
in the jungle or the Miracle on Ice had
the power to transcend each sports fan
base the drama involved bridged the gap
between hardcore fans and those that
ordinarily had little to no interest in
the sport making each one a historic
touchstone
[Music]
[Applause]
competitive gaming has its fair share of
similarly iconic moments Daigo Umehara
'he's jaw-dropping counter-attack
against justin wong and evo 2004 the
taipei assassins unexpected reign of
terror at league of legends world's 2012
all the ridiculous series of fountain
hooks during the battle between navi &
tongfu a dota 2 'the 2013 international
are just a few but these have become a
legendary within isolated communities
among people that have intimate
understanding of complex game systems
and have followed disjointed stories
over the course of months and in some
cases years overwatch is played by 40
million people around the world its
design strikes numerous parallels to
traditional team-based sports making the
key moments of drama happening in the
midst of the action easier to connect
with this approachability opens the door
to watching eSports wider than it has
ever been before and the league serves
as a place where stories can be
cultivated and moments of drama can be
showcased on a bigger stage in front of
a broader audience
but while / which breaks down many of
the barriers other games have faced
Blizzard still has multiple hurdles to
overcome relating to public perception
of eSports and eSports athletes before
they can truly realize their vision for
the league eSports is definitely
regarded as lesser than traditional
sports still I think here in the States
and in Western society I think you have
a lot of people who go oh you sit in a
chair and you play video game that's not
a sport that's ridiculous it's kind of a
silly debate to me it's competition it's
entertaining millions of people want to
watch it who cares what you call it
the vast majority of us are physically
incapable of doing what our pro players
do there is actually a physical
component like when you watch carp a
play Widowmaker you physically cannot do
that
that's the counter snipe on the baby
they dock freeze my bow that that goes
down carp a totally going wild on this
Widowmaker right now so you can have the
debate all night long about is it is
there a physical an opponent is it a
sport is not sport I'm past that debate
it's it's like how do we how do we just
continue to do what we're doing and make
it better I really feel like I grew up
in the generation where for a lot of us
it was not looked upon great that you
played games it was actually something
to be slightly embarrassed about you
know gamers were looked at us you know
anti-social nerds and it wasn't heavily
embraced games were looked at as a toy
you know if you were playing games as an
adult that was something to be ashamed
--fill of and I love that we now live in
an era where games are broadly accepted
and looked at as a part of popular
culture they're looked at as art they're
looked at as entertainment they're
looked at as a extremely successful
business and I'd like to think that we
could get there with eSports as well we
all grew up with video games that's all
we know but the generation before us
didn't maybe it's a little bit harder
for them to accept I think for
Millennials and Gen Z it's it's an easy
buy-in you know this is what we know
this is what we do what people often
miss about gaming because people think
gaming is like this like fleeting hobby
it's like this thing I'm gonna do and
I'm a kid and then like I'll grow out of
it but that's not what it is it's
actually like my identity and it's it's
a part of who I am like I spend so much
time doing this playing games I spend so
much time investing in this community
being a part of it like it's only
natural that I want to see who's
despite the intent behind the overwatch
League it's still a gamble for Blizzard
unlike many other games it's skipped the
grassroots phase of cultivating a
dedicated eSports scene opting to invest
heavily in its vision for a new kind of
eSports entertainment that's open to
everyone to that end it is set up an
arena for live matches to take place in
courted celebrity investors to buy into
permanent team franchises and rolled out
ambitious broadcasting plans this has
all been done with thee if you build it
they will come
mindset for Blizzard giving overwatch
fans the means to throw themselves
deeper into their passion is a small
step toward the bigger dream for the
league but if it is to establish the
future of eSports entertainment the real
challenge is reaching beyond just those
people in the next episode of this
series we'll be going behind the scenes
at the blizzard Arena and talking with
the people charged with taking the
fast-paced action of overwatch and
transforming it into a spectator
experience with all the grandeur of
traditional sports
[Music]
you